uh Peter wants me to ask you about
Andrew Tate what do you think about that
situation I I think that um Andrew Tate
uh most of what he said I agree with
fully I mean it's stuff that you know
bread and butter for you and guys like
you and me right uh I thought that
um
I saw some video of it some some short
little clip video that said that he said
he said that you know the way they come
at you is that first they cancel you
then they arrest you and then they
outright you away with you okay and he
was absolutely right and so once they
canceled him across social media
I respectfully I I don't have any beef
with the guy at all but I think that he
should have prepared better and not been
in the place like Romania I think that
frankly he should have gone to the Far
East
to one of the the you know Asian
countries where he would have been able
to continue and really be secure that
the Americans aren't going to reach out
and grab him as they did because as I
understand the case at this point he's
being charged with human trafficking but
there are no victims and and they
haven't charging with anything yet
apparently okay but the the suspicion
that he was trafficking uh girls for sex
or God knows what well there are no
credible Witnesses and a lot of the
women who are associated with him say no
no no no we could leave whenever we want
to we have our passports in hand I mean
no problem we were there of our own
volition and you know these women have
the incentive now to say oh yes Andrew
Tate was an evil guy so the fact that
they're saying no no he didn't do
anything nor did his brother do anything
it leads me to conclude that it's all
just [__] the fact that they haven't
charged him with anything is more proof
that's [__] I personally don't think
that he's going to be released anytime
soon I mean
I you know like Julian Assange Julian
Assange
committed no crime in the United States
he is not an American citizen and yet
he's going to be extraded to the United
States and probably be thrown into some
concrete [__] for the rest of his
life
you know the Americans do this once once
the once they're you're in their sights
that's what the Americans do and they
obviously have a hard on for Andrew Tate
why I mean what did he do he didn't even
release like Secrets like Julian Assange
did he just said a lot of things that
most people would find perfectly
reasonable and and the the splitter that
is controversial it's just not social
issues he's just a [__] guy talking
okay I mean he's not like creating like
a political movement or advocating
violence or anything of the sort right
he's just frankly he's a loud mouth like
you and me okay
what crime did he possibly commit no
it's just they wanted to [__] him over
and I think that's almost like there's
Christmas the Christmas it's almost like
there's like a level of of like
loudmouth that you can aspire to and
then once you go go beyond that Line in
the Sand then you're flying too close to
the Sun and I think that's what he did
you know he just you know and and he
also
um what was the term that was used a lot
uh self uh snitching
um he said a lot of things I think in
Jess personally because I think he's got
a great sense of humor
he seems like a funny guy I mean
way out of context right
of course yeah anyway I mean there are
some people who are approved like Jordan
Peterson uh Jordan Peterson they allow
him to exist because he toes the line on
certain issues
and and I mean he he talks about uh male
disenfranchisement and and the abuse
that men are suffering but at the same
time he toes the line on for instance on
Israel he was Towing the line on the
backs he was Towing the line he is
Towing the line on the Ukraine conflict
um so that's why he's allowed to exist
let Andrew Tate uh was true to what he
thought
and he doesn't tell anybody's lying and
so he got [__] over okay and I agree
with you you could there's a range where
when you're very low they can cancel you
out very easily when you're in that
middle range that I would argue that
both you and I are at ah they basically
let us say whatever we want to but if
you get too high too big that's when
they really go for you and that's what
happened to Andrew Tate and and in fact
you know I think part of the reason they
went after Andrew Tate was to make it
make him an example a lesson for people
like you and I to shut the [__] up or
just tone it down I think that that was
a big part of the motivation
do you think that Jordan Peterson offers
uh remedies to chaos in the world right
now no
he's very good at giving a diagnosis of
what is happening but he doesn't look at
the root cause because I think that he
fundamentally knows the root causes but
he doesn't dare speak them because of
course it would offend people in power
it would identify people in power that's
the problem
you know yeah he did a um you know he's
he's all tied up with the daily wire
crowd right now and I um you know I got
noticed by the way there's there's
something else too that I have to
mention about Jordan Peterson he seems
emotionally unstable
I mean it seems very emotionally
unstable he he doesn't seem like a guy
who can really handle [__] okay uh I
remember a year or two ago he was doing
some interviewing he started like crying
and [__] like what the [__] is going on
quite often yeah you know I mean you
know like I'll cry if like a a a child
or a dog dies you know yeah sure but
like over my [__] feelings [__] off
I'm sorry that was just [__] to me
yeah one of the things that like grinds
my gears with Jordan Peterson is you
know he gets a lot of worship and I
think you know for the most part he
offers
he offers something positive you know
like clean your room stand up straight
wash your dick like you know basic stuff
right clean your house you know have
your own house in order but then but
then he goes down these paths like he
did with the whole daily wire thing and
then he started doing these private
broadcasts about uh marriage and so I
thought to myself okay well you know I I
have a chapter in my book about why
smart men should no longer marry in the
west and I wanted to see what his take
on it was it was behind the paywall I
did a cast on my on my um unplugged
Alpha podcast channel so if you guys
want to watch you can go find that but
basically the long and short of it was
it was don't be a [__] man up you know
you have a Biblical obligation to get
married and have children
um don't worry about you know the risks
just just be a man and negotiate your
way through your marriage sort of thing
and it's like that is just [__] advice
and I said so and I broke it down you
know in detail you know why so I think
he marches some too many guys in the
slaughterhouse and I think the other
thing that bugs me about him too is you
know he's always about you know get your
house in order and you know here you
have his daughter good advice it's good
advice you know it's good advice but I
mean like you know here you have him
suffering with some sort of addiction
and again this was years ago to I I
can't remember what it was but he had to
go to Russia and his daughter's husband
at the time brought him there and they
all traveled together apparently with
the kid and then she took off for
several days to go visit Andrew Tate in
Romania while she's still married left
the kid behind while her father's in
[__] to talk business yes sure you
guys read between the lines you know
yeah yeah I I really want to talk
business with like lots of online you
know I'll give them my business card and
a few other things I suppose uh the
woman is a [__] and and manipulated her
father I mean the guy simps for his own
daughter that's creepy you know but
um look I I mean how can I put it
I respect him because he's extremely
successful with this book and and the
way he's he's of course yeah okay deal
of money off of his videos I mean good
on him I don't have a problem with that
right I respond this position of being
purely uh
compelled speech you know I I fully
agree with that I I shouldn't be forced
to call people as I see fit you know uh
but um but the other stuff you know I I
you know he he he lost his marbles I
think when he got that high he didn't
know how to handle it you know and so um
I mean I I'm sort of like you know of
two minds there I see a lot of benefits
to the guy
uh but at the same time yeah like you
said uh telling people telling guys to
March into the slaughterhouse I mean one
of my most popular videos was the video
I did where I said never marry a single
never date a single mother because
there's no upside to you you know you're
going to be expending resources on some
other man's kid and the woman is just
really latching on to you because you're
a life rafter right financially at least
and and perhaps emotionally and so don't
do it right and I don't see what it's
not gonna Focus yeah the single mothers
yeah yeah exactly and so I have a
chapter on the topic yeah you and I are
on the same page on that yeah exactly I
mean it's funny
you and I came to some great Insight
it's this [__] common logic I mean
just common sense not not for all men
though I mean like even even for me at
one point I I made that same mistake too
right but it's making those mistakes
that have helps you realize and
distinguish the difference like you need
contrast you can't you can't relate to
Darkness without light obviously right
yeah yeah and so anyway
um I lost my train of thought but anyway
about the single mother thing you know
he he's he's telling people to to March
into that slaughterhouse which is stupid
you know
and so and look the way things are going
the women in the west are rapidly
deteriorating they're becoming just you
know unconscionable I mean no that's the
wrong word uh they're just insufferable
that's the word I was looking for women
in the west are insufferable and uh they
they are just uh we're seeing the end
effects of the complete deregulation of
the sexual marketplace where it becomes
a free-for-all and so who benefits the
top tier guys they're the guys who get
all the girls and all the girls are
uninterested in the guys who are
actually at that level you have these
porkers right and they're real workers
we're talking about chicks that are like
you know
175 pounds and they're only like five
feet two and they expect the average
weight of a North American woman today
by the way it's about 175 pounds five
foot two five and three yeah you know
um you know they're they're
um
they're looking for a six foot two Chad
who makes uh you know 250 a year and has
got a six inch dick what's that the
three sixes uh six foot six sixes yeah
oh whatever the [__] you know they have
these unrealistic expectations and top
tier guys where do they look at them
they look at them as come dumpsters to
be perfectly vulgar about it you know I
I know that your audience is mostly guys
so so I don't I don't I I figure it's
better to say it straight they're just
come dumpsters come on you know I I've
told the story I was on the fit and fit
uh fresh and fitness
um podcast fresh and fit yeah yeah Myron
show yeah it was great we wound up
talking for four and a half [__]
hours man it just flew by it was just a
lot of fun talking to those guys you
know but anyway I I told them a story
that uh that back in the year 2000 I was
driving around all of North America with
my dog on my Land Rover and I I stayed
at this hostel in uh in Fairbanks and
there was nobody else there because it
was water it down a bit on my channel
because I know that they that they
amplify a little bit of this for like
red meat and I just want to make sure I
don't run into problems with YouTube but
just yeah carry on with the story but
just water it down a bit okay and anyway
there was this um you know 300 pounder
there you know and yeah I banged her
yeah
I can't be so crazy and so you know
detached that I'll have a chance to like
you know you know pork some Buffalo
right and uh it was just funny as hell
but it was the one time it was just for
kicks right
um you know like like you know you
look in my 30s I was a real degenerate
guy and I [__] but I [__] everything
that moved right and most of the time it
was just just to check off the list you
know Asians Japanese Koreans Vietnamese
you know uh European chicks accident
chicks everything whatever you know but
uh yeah and one of the most important I
also did a woman who was like 22 years
older than me you know yeah it's just
yeah that's amazing dear God but the
point you must have had a long list to
go through to accomplish all of that I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out